last year some BuzzFeed employees were
scheming to prank their boss say Frank
on his birthday they decided to put a
family of baby goats in his office now
BuzzFeed had recently signed on to the
Facebook live experiment and so
naturally we decided to livestream the
whole event on the Internet to capture
the moment when they would walk in and
discover livestock in his office we
thought the whole thing would last maybe
10 minutes and a few hundred company
employees would log in for the inside
joke but what happened they kept on
getting delayed you wanted to get a
drink he was called to a meeting the
meeting ran long he went to the bathroom
more and more people started logging in
to watch the goats by the time they
walked in more than 30 minutes later
ninety thousand viewers were watching
the live stream now our team had a lot
of discussion about this video and why
it was so successful it wasn't the
biggest live video that we had done
today the biggest one that we had done
involved a fountain of cheese but it had
performed it so much better than we had
expected what was it about the goats in
the office that we didn't anticipate now
a reasonable person could have any
number of hypotheses maybe people love
baby animals
maybe people love office pranks maybe
people love stories about their bosses
or birthday surprises but our team
wasn't really thinking about what the
video was about we were thinking about
what the people watching the video were
thinking and feeling we read some of the
82,000 comments that were made during
the video and we hypothesized that they
were excited because they were
participating in the
shared anticipation of something that
was about to happen they were part of a
community just for an instant and it
made them happy so we decided that we
need to test the hypothesis what could
we do to test this very same thing the
following week armed with the additional
knowledge that food videos are very
popular we dressed two people in hazmat
suits and wrapped rubber bands around a
watermelon until it exploded 800,000
people watched the 690 a--the rubber
band
explode the watermelon marking it as the
biggest Facebook live event to date the
question I get most frequently is how do
you make something go viral the question
itself is misplaced
it's not about the something it's about
what the people doing the something
reading or watching what are they
thinking
now most media companies when they think
about metadata they think about subjects
or formats
it's about goats it's about office
pranks it's about food it's a list or a
video or a quiz it's 2,000 words long
it's 15 minutes long it has 23 embedded
tweets or 15 images now that kind of
metadata is mildly interesting but it
doesn't actually get at what really
matters what if instead of tagging what
articles or videos are about what have
we asked how is it helping our users do
a real job in their lives last year we
started a project to formally categorize
our content in this way
we called it cultural cartography it
formalized in formal practice that we've
had for a really long time don't just
think about the subject matter think
also about and in fact primarily about
the job that your content is doing for
the reader or the viewer let me show you
the map that we have today each bubble
is a specific job and each group of
bubbles and a specific color are related
jobs first up humor makes me laugh
there's so many ways to
you make somebody laugh you could be
laughing at someone you could laugh at
specific internet humor you could be
laughing at some good clean inoffensive
dad jokes this is me identity people are
increasingly using media to explain this
is Who I am
this is knife upbringing this is my
culture this is my fandom this is my
guilty pleasure and this is how I laugh
about myself
helps me connect with another person
this is one of the greatest gifts of the
Internet it's amazing when you find a
piece of media that precisely describes
your bond with someone this is a group
of jobs that helps me do something helps
me settle an argument helps me learn
something about myself or another person
or helps me explain my story this is
group of jobs it makes me feel something
makes me curious or sad or restores my
faith in humanity many media companies
and creators do put themselves in their
audiences shoes but in the age of social
media you can go much farther people are
connected to each other on Facebook on
Twitter and they're increasingly using
media to have a conversation and to talk
to each other if we can be a part of
establishing a deeper connection between
two people then we will have done a real
job for these people let me give you
some examples of how this plays out this
is one of my favorite lists 32 memes you
should send your sister immediately
immediately for example when you're
going through your sister stuff and you
hear coming up the stairs absolutely
I've done that watching your sister get
in trouble for something that you did
and blamed on her yes I've done that as
well this list got three million views
why is that because it did very well
several jobs this is us connect with
family makes me laugh here are some of
the thousands and thousands of comments
that sister sent to each other using
this list sometimes we discover what
jobs do after the fact this quiz pick an
outfit and will guess your exact agen
height went very viral 10 million views
10 million views I mean did we actually
determine the exact
to age and height of 10 million people
that's incredible it's incredible in
fact we didn't turns out that this quiz
went extremely viral among a group of 55
and up women who were surprised and
delighted that BuzzFeed determined that
they were twenty eight and five nine
they put me at thirty four years younger
and seven inches taller I dressed for
comfort did I give a damn what anyone
says age is a state of mind this quiz
was successful not because it was
accurate but because it allowed these
ladies to do a very important job
the humblebrag now we can even apply
this framework to recipes and food now a
recipes normal job is to tell you what
to make for dinner or for lunch and this
is how you would normally brainstorm for
a recipe you figure out what ingredients
you want to use what recipe that makes
and then maybe you slap a job on at the
end to sell it but what if we flipped it
around it's not about the job first
so one brainstorming session involved
the job of bonding so could we make a
recipe that brought people together this
is not a normal brainstorming process at
a food publisher so we know that people
like to bake together and we know that
people like to do challenges together so
we decided to come up with a recipe that
involved those two things and we
challenged ourselves could we get people
to say hey BFF let's see if we can do
this together the resulting video was
the fuzziest brownies ever video it was
enormous ly successful in every metric
possible 70 million views and people
said the exact things that we were going
after hey Colette we need to make these
are yet for a challenge game on it did
the job that is set out to do which was
to bring people together over baking and
chocolate
I am really excited about the potential
for this project when we talk about this
framework with our content creators they
instantly get it no matter what beat the
cover or country they're in or what
language they speak
so cultural cartography has helped us
massively scale our workforce training
when we talk about this project with in
this framework with advertisers and
brands they also instantly get it
because advertisers in ways more more
often than media companies understand
how important it is to understand the
job that their products are doing for
customers but the reason I'm I'm the
most excited about this project is
because it changes the relationship
between media and data most media
companies think about media as mine how
many fans do I have how many followers
have I gained how many views have I
gotten how many unique IDs do I have in
my data warehouse but that misses the
true value of data which is that it's
yours if we can capture in data what
really matters to you then and if we can
understand more the role to our work
plays in your actual life the better
content we can create for you and the
better that we can reach you who are you
how did you get there where are you
going when you care about what can you
teach us
that's cultural cartography thank you
[Applause]